i felt like you also like you were doing
some small things that made people root
against you
oh there would be like you know like
maybe it'd be like the kendrick lamar is
a weirdo rapper line when like can
everyone's [ __ ] with kendrick yes
this is just all of them okay let's just
address this just one by one that was on
new york city i was in new york city
album now that's what i'm trying to say
you do
when you do some real [ __ ] it's like
whoa whoa whoa that's too real i didn't
know
i came in the game like thinking
like i put it to wwe wrestling i always
seen the wrestlers growing up i thought
they was real [ __ ] they doing this okay
when somebody say something about you
when snoop say he crushed the buildings
nori and uh cnn came at him a couple
other people whatever came like turn
[ __ ] up yeah that's how you post you
posted react and defend that's what i
thought it was you know i'm saying so
when
when [ __ ] uh kendrick lamar said the
[ __ ] about new york and everybody had
their paintings and a bunch of [ __ ] i'm
like god all you
[ __ ] making whole songs is
that's why is it that my one my my
[ __ ] one bar stuck more than wait
wait
you said was that before the control
freestyle no it was after after why
would i say that i don't know
that make no sense so like i'm only
everything like people with those stones
and they hide their hands they only see
the reaction because my reaction is so
aggressive and
savage but there's no rules to a
reaction like i say if somebody slap you
and you mind in your business they slap
you and you get up and you [ __ ]
bludgeon them or beat them with a bat
they should have never slapped you so
everybody making whole diss records
about
kendrick lamar because he said to new
york right i think jay-z even did a
verse and just never put it out right
like mad people had records and it was
just nothing but this one line
by a little old independent choice i
just think i just think it's so hard
yeah and i didn't say nothing crazy how
to capture you didn't say anything super
disrespectful i just i said he's a
weirdo rapper which which was like but
now [ __ ] want to use widow
rappers as a term now like it was a
widow rapper compared to the [ __ ] you
were doing
not me doing just
see this is what i don't like i don't
like when media people
everybody try to act like
try to just have alternative facts
if
from the look you got a bunch of [ __ ]
plaques on here right from these people
we grew up looking at the clips these
same [ __ ] people packing big
if they were like
because you got me talking about it see
how when kendrick lamar came out on
stage and he had the white [ __ ] on
mm-hmm you know what i'm saying yeah
that was yeah that was recently yeah
right like
i mean but he's just out of the roots
and jizz on the wall and kanye up there
yeah you know kanye is fire the root
state the roots you know what they all
mean
like there's nothing wrong with having
there's nothing wrong with people having
titles i mean and also that if that was
if that was like a retort for the
control freestyle it makes sense that's
all it was i mean that's all it was
every single one of my songs since day
one for my mixtape it always been new
york i even had my singles yo new york
while everybody else was trying to dick
right and sound like no for sure you
definitely like all these first bricks
in the backpack [ __ ] like well i don't
know how many songs i got about brooklyn
how many songs i got about new york and
i'm spending my own money to promote
this when i know it'll keep me local but
by me keep pushing and pushing i'm
repping i'm loyal to where i'm from
right and everybody should be like that
i love when i love when i come where i
hear yg first album and it should sound
like ellen yeah you feel me when you
hear
new york city albums sound like new york
you know what i'm saying i want to hear
[ __ ] young thugs sounding like
atlanta or or young jeezy [ __ ] you know
what i mean like shit's gotta sound like
where it's from
there's nothing wrong with collabing
when big got with bone thug that was the
perfect collaboration sure that's
filming he kept his new york voice and
he did their friends
and that did it better than them
i don't know i i'm bored
now so oh my god
oh man